Let's go through it together.
Href is actually one of the arguments to this anchor tag.
It's not displayed.
If the user clicks on this link, they'll go to Wikipedia.org,
but they'll never see the href. This is not shown.
Mary, on the other hand, is not the name of a tag or the argument to a tag.
It will be shown.
Similarly, Vindication will be shown.
It'll be shown as part of a link and italicized, but it'll be there.
Wikipedia is part of the argument to this anchor tag,so it will not be shown.
Wrote, however, will be shown, and then this i, the italic tag, isn't shown.
Instead, the next is actually slanted.
Here we're taking a look at how it would render in a web browser.
We can see Mary Wollstonecraft wrote A Vindication of the Rights of Women.
Href, Wikipedia, and i are not printed on the screen.